[Musique]
america du le mot insaisissable revient
souvent lorsqu'on parle de vous et bien
d'où cette paix tant ses grands coups
d'éclat qu'on voit parfois sur scène
avec la voix ou avec les jeunes c'est
mon tempérament je pense ça c'est
quelque chose qu'on travaille pas j'ai
un tempérament intense je viens d'une
famille où les doutes de gens assez qui
sont comme ça disait qu intensité peut
être caractérisé bon à la ville
peut-être que ça sert pas tout le temps
mais sur scène à l'écran c'est
intéressant chez attirés par des
personnages qui ont une certaine forme
intensité qui correspond pour la main
mon tempérament moins contrôler trois
points de suspension mais risque pour le
dire moi la tentation crois que la
réponse soit parce que ces derniers
jouent beaucoup de personnages les
bronzés c'est comme des rôles qui me
colle un collège où son nom mais vous
savez les personnages intéressants
toujours un type de névrose certains
personnages capote de l'ehpad aspire t
vote un peu plus ou moins intéressants à
travailler donc les grands personnages
de théâtre les faits soient dits de
grandes choses ils ont des tournois où
son nom d'un côté comme et comme un peu
plus ou alors je me vois pas comme
quelqu'un de bronzé ou juin que des
névrosés mais je dirais que joue un
personnage belge en général pas si
intéressante et folie de tourments la
dernière fois qu'on s'est rencontrés
c'est être juste avant coriolan centre
du nouveau monde à l'arrière scène tout
allait bien mais vous sembliez un peu
nerveuse pourtant j'avais vu les
répétitions tout allait bien mais vous
vous avez encore le doute vous êtes mois
seulement habité par le doute
mais je pense qu'avant la rencontre avec
le public se fasse c'est très difficile
d'être d'être confiant à 0 c'est pas un
doute qui nous qui nous empêche de
compte rien avancer mais c'est un doute
je pense raisonnable ou un doute sain
parce que rien n'est gagné
avant même après 37 ans d'expérience à
voir parce que sinon quoi on sait ce
qu'on fait on va le faire puis on ne
sait jamais non sincèrement on ne sait
pas on a des intuitions
on espère par exemple là on est dans le
décor de petra von kant séparer avant la
première on a peu dans le vide jusqu'à
un certain point tant qu'il ya pas eu
cette rencontre avec le public c'est
très très difficile de savoir dans quel
objet on si tu regardes à votre
curriculum vitae il fait quatre pages
d'ailleurs est ce que je peut se poser
la question suivante est ce que vous
aviez pensé quand même un fil continu
dans tout ce que vous avez fait des
commencé par le théâtre et beaucoup de
cinéma télévision appartenant à 90 est
là aujourd'hui c'est à peu près tout
vous avez déjà reçu des gros compris oui
oh oui mais oui parce que vous le
regrettez aujourd'hui n'ont jamais non
mais non parce que si je les refuse et
c'est parce qu'il faut je veux bien
croire parfois on refuse un contrat qui
peut être payant tu devrais
financièrement mais si on peut pour bien
se projeter pour bien se dit je vais
exiger d'avoir le jouer je vais devoir
bon alors c'est pas la valeur ultime de
faire de
faire de l'argent parce qu'on disait
apprécier vers autre chose qui va venir
il faut avoir confiance un peu un sens
quand on croit parce que vous avez
jamais manqué de travail refus non non
ça c'est vrai j'ai manqué de travail je
dis moi je compte bien continuer prépare
mais j'ai des modèles
janine sutto avant qu'elle qu'elle
marque ça ce sont des femmes qui sont en
plus ce sont des femmes généreuses qui
ont donné à la génération qui suivit
elles ont été très généreuse avec nous
alors j'espère que je vais l'être aussi
avec les plus jeunes
c'est important parce que il ya toute
une génération qui monte qui est
vraiment intéressante pour moi aussi
travailler ici on a des concepts les
secteurs des femmes
décors costumes éclairages et dès que ça
antoine moutain aussi qui plus jeune
travailler avec une jeune fille six ans
c'est fantastique quand ils font appel à
nous puis j'ai eu de la chance
dernièrement d'avoir plusieurs zones de
plus jeunes metteurs en scène dont
j'étais contente ont redonné aux plus
jeunes aux plus jeunes femmes oui un
vent de changement à vous sentez ce qui
souffle fort vous l'attendiez depuis
longtemps oui oui je trouve qu'il n'ya
pas assez de mai le sas à sa montre
parce qu'il ya eu 7
toutacoo remarks moi ça fait longtemps
que j'en mangerais dé programmation
complète avec que des metteurs en scène
comme que liquide home je voyais puis on
se dit personne vraiment en parle on en
parle
évidemment ça va changer les choses et
ça commençait à changer nuit plusieurs
vies plusieurs autres is plusieurs
metteurs en scène comme j'ai des
concepts très sensible ça va ça me va
ça va donner quelque chose c'est la
parole des femmes c'est sur 24 merci la
seule façon de supporter la
compréhension du mans
c'est d'essayer de faire preuve
d'humilité je me fasse à mon travail je
me fasse à l'argent que je gagne